SPEAKER 1: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a large number of talks
detailing the future of cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch the session "Managing
Container Engine Clusters
Across Multiple Teams,"
then stay tuned, because
here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As development teams
embark into Kubernetes,
they will inevitably need to
revisit their project, cluster,
and namespace organization
as new teams need access,
or as they prepare
for production
into multiple environments.
SPEAKER 2: This brings up the
ever-common question of how
do I configure my environment.
In practice, we see three
typical configurations.
SPEAKER 1: First is a shared
project, shared cluster,
and different namespace,
where namespaces
map to different teams.
The benefit of this is that
it gives you potential cost
savings in proper isolation.
But now, resource isolation
is limited to CPU and memory.
SPEAKER 2: The second is one
project, different cluster,
different namespace setup, which
gives you improved resource
isolation.
But you might lose
management benefits.
SPEAKER 1: Third is different
project, different cluster,
and different
namespace, which offers
greater isolation
and billing control,
but again, lost
management benefits.
SPEAKER 2: But after
a lot of discussions,
one of the most
powerful setups has
to be doing a different project
for production, separating
dev test and production,
along with shared clusters
and different namespaces
for each team.
SPEAKER 1: Now, once
you have things isolated
the way you like,
you can optimize
for resources offered
to them to optimize
your quality of service.
By specifying CPU and memory
limits on your containers,
the scheduler can give
you a different quality
of service based on
resource requests
for your pod, either
best effort, burstable,
or guaranteed.
SPEAKER 2: Of
course, you now run
into the problem about what
the resource requests should
be set to.
Without a strong
history of data,
there's a big
chance you're going
to get these numbers
wrong for a while.
To help with that,
Kubernetes has a feature
called initial
resources, which looks
at the history of resource
usage for a container
and sets the request
automatically based
on that history so that
once you've run a container,
you don't need to specify the
request again in the future.
The system essentially learns
what the right resource request
is by observing it
across multiple runs.
SPEAKER 1: For more information
about how to properly set up
your Kubernetes
environment, including
some demos and other
insights, check out
the full talk on YouTube.
If you're looking
for more recaps
on other great
Next content, make
sure to check out the
rest of our playlist.
And don't forget
the next world tour,
coming soon to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]